[Música]
se controla la mayor parte de
severodonezk que junto al issys jones es
el centro de la ofensiva para capturar
la provincia de lugansk y el este del
país mientras tanto la unión europea
logró aprobar las nuevas sanciones al
petróleo ruso con miras a una
prohibición del 90 por ciento de
importaciones para fin de año
el senado de chile ratificó el acuerdo
de escazú primer tratado ambiental de
américa latina' y único del mundo que
busca la protección de sus activistas en
el continente donde más son asesinados y
perseguidos
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal en
santiago
y son al menos 11 fallecidos y más de 30
desaparecidos en mexico por el paso de
agatha que tocó tierra como huracán este
lunes en oaxaca en el sur del país y que
ya se degradó a tormenta tropical es el
primer evento de la temporada de
huracanes y se esperan al menos 40
fenómenos similares hasta noviembre
cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela gómez
y aquí están las noticias de france 24
comenzamos con noticias de ucrania rusia
controla la mayor parte de la ciudad
industrial de severodonezk clave en la
ofensiva del kremlin para tomarse del
este del país la caída de severodonezk y
de su vecina lis y sants que implicaría
la captura total de la provincia de
lugansk sin embargo el presidente de
volodymyr selenski dijo que las tropas
invasoras se han enfrentado a una dura
resistencia el gobernador regional del
lugar que dijo que casi toda la
infraestructura crítica en sebero donges
que fue destruida y que el 60% de
hogares sufrieron daños irreparables de
otro lado la unión europea sancionó dos
tercios de las importaciones de petróleo
ruso
un movimiento que consolida la unidad
del bloque europeo frente a la crisis en
ucrania luego de dos días de discusiones
los países de la unión europea lograron
el consenso necesario para disminuir en
un 90% las importaciones de petróleo
ruso una acción que busca presionar a
moscú para el retiro de sus tropas de
ucrania restar el rescoldo y este de
comenzamos con el carbón ayer en audio
de la noche decidimos prohibir ahora de
facto el 90 por ciento de las
importaciones de petróleo ruso a la
unión europea para fin de año ping yan
variando khtey a rusia en la actualidad
suministra el 27 por ciento del petróleo
y un 40% del gas que se consume en la
unión europea la acción contempla un
bloqueo de todo el petróleo que llega
por vía marítima al bloque y prevé
exenciones al petróleo que llega por
oleoductos la iniciativa forma parte de
un sexto paquete de sanciones que
adelanta el bloque europeo en contra de
moscú que ya tendría un principio de
acuerdo
yo creo que es una señal muy fuerte que
enviamos hoy porque en las últimas horas
hubo especulaciones sobre el riesgo de
una falta de unidad de la unión europea
por otro lado los 27 integrantes de la
unión europea expresaron su preocupación
por el bloqueo de las exportaciones
ucranianas a través del mar negro por
parte de rusia por ello turquía ha
iniciado labores para permitir la salida
a estos productos y evitar una crisis de
alimentos mundial de turquía gold es un
portón con túnez turquía tiene un papel
muy importante debido a su
responsabilidad en el mar negro debido a
los tratados existentes vi que el
intercambio entre el presidente erdogán
y el presidente putin fue bastante
positivo espero que los próximos días
las próximas semanas permitan solucionar
esta situación de fusiones rojos pues en
su mente al método de closet situación
la acción de la unión europea generó una
caída de la bolsa de moscú y un alza en
el precio del barril de petróleo este 31
de mayo
el senado de chile ratificó el acuerdo
de escazú la adhesión al primer tratado
ambiental de américa latina' y único en
su clase por enfocarse en la protección
de activistas se alcanzó con el 31 votos
a favor 3 en contra y 11 abstenciones el
gobierno de gabriel bobridge había
solicitado en marzo debatirlo con
urgencia los detalles los entregó desde
santiago nuestra corresponsal patricia
luna pues como muy bien señalaba fue una
de las primeras prioridades el primer
acto de gobierno que realizó el
presidente gabriel boric el día 12 de
marzo un día después de asumir pedir
este que este tratado fuera aceptado en
el congreso con máxima urgencia a partir
de ahí ha habido muchas labores de parte
del tanto del ministerio de medio
ambiente como de cancillería para dejar
bien en claro que éste sería el primer
gobierno ecológico de chile que tiene
como prioridad
retornar al acuerdo de escazú en
relación a lo que sucedió en él
administración pasada y también poner
como prioridad los temas
medioambientales sobre la mesa en chile
en relación a sus promesas de campaña
en méxico el fenómeno ágata que tocó
tierra en el sur del país como huracán
este lunes ella es una tormenta tropical
sin embargo a su paso por el estado de
oaxaca dejó al menos 11 muertos y más de
30 desaparecidos según el gobierno local
todavía hay alerta en decenas de
municipios en riesgo por inundaciones
salva santana nos amplia
el inicio de la temporada de huracanes
en méxico ha llegado con fuerza de hecho
agatha tocó suelo en el estado de oaxaca
dejando muertos y desaparecidos a su
paso y también en destrucción como ha
pasado aquí en san pedro de pochutla
tipo ahorita con esta pérdida pues para
volvernos a reparar va a ser un poco
difícil y porque perdimos todo lo que es
lo eléctrico se lo sentenció la agua
todo y pues ya no tenemos ni para tomar
pero pues ahorita a ver si por lo menos
llega la ayuda de que nos apoyen con
agua con comida o con lo que se pueda
pues ágata es el primer huracán de la
temporada 2022 en el pacífico y a pesar
de que ha perdido fuerza tras su paso
por el sur de méxico fue calificado como
un huracán peligroso ya que puso en
alerta máxima a 75 municipios con
vientos de hasta 170 kilómetros por hora
olas de hasta 8 metros de altura y
deslizamientos de tierra están sacando
todo lo que puedan de su casa porque
totalmente está inundado más que nada
hay que
procurar sacar todo lo que es
material bueno no porque lo demás se lo
va a llevar todo se prevé que la ahora
tormenta tropical siga provocando
lluvias en el estado de oaxaca por lo
que existe riesgo de inundaciones en la
zona con el inicio de la temporada de
huracanes que va de mayo a noviembre a
méxico todavía le esperan a muchos más
con un pronóstico de hasta 40 de estos
fenómenos para 2022
vamos a china porque finalizaron dos
meses de uno de los mayores bloqueos por
kobe 19 del mundo con su política de
'cero tolerancia' del país congeló la
vida en shanghai a un alto costo humano
y económico pero hoy cuando ya amaneció
el miércoles en asia los habitantes del
distrito económico celebraron el regreso
de la normalidad sin embargo se mantiene
el temor a nuevos brotes entre los 25
millones de residentes que ahora pueden
salir libremente de sus casas e ir a
trabajar y usar transporte público a la
medianoche cuando expiró la prohibición
pequeños grupos reunidos en el antiguo
barrio de la concesión francesa de la
ciudad
silbaron el gritaron y chocaron las
copas
continúan las deliberaciones de los
jurados para llegar a un veredicto en el
caso que compromete a los actores johnny
depp y su expareja amber hearn de backus
a hertz de difamarlo con acusaciones de
abuso doméstico y exige 50 millones de
dólares por daños y perjuicios hertz por
su parte contra demandó por de 100
millones de dólares
ambos se acusan mutuamente de difamación
con las cámaras en la sala el juicio de
la ex pareja ha sido visto por cientos
de millones de personas en todo el mundo
expertos legales dicen que ambos podrían
perder la batalla ninguna de las partes
ha podido demostrar realmente sus
argumentos ninguna de las partes ha
vinculado algún tipo de disminución en
su carreras con las declaraciones
específicas por las que están demandando
el caso gira en torno a un artículo
escrito por amber heard en 2018 en el
que se describe a sí misma como una
figura pública que representa el abuso
doméstico aunque no menciona a johnny
depp por su nombre su equipo alega que
el artículo dañó la reputación del actor
haciéndole perder trabajo y demandan 50
millones de dólares por daños y
perjuicios
cuando se hicieron las acusaciones
cuando las acusaciones dieron
rápidamente la vuelta al mundo diciendo
que yo era una amenaza borracho y lleno
de cocaína que pegaba a las mujeres de
repente a mis 50 años se acabó ya sabes
estás acabado
ha contrademandado por 100 millones de
dólares diciendo que de la es prestigio
cuando su abogado calificó sus
afirmaciones de bromas el juicio ha
revelado una relación problemática de
bbva afirma que se le cortó el dedo con
una botella rota ella por su parte le
acusa de un patrón de comportamiento
violento incluida la agresión sexual es
horrible para mí sentarme aquí durante
semanas y revivir todo esto gente que
conocía algunos bien otros no mis marido
con el que compartí mi vida hablar de
nuestras vidas de la manera que lo han
hecho esto ha sido esto es lo más
doloroso y difícil que he pasado sin
dudas en el contexto del movimiento
mitsu el juicio ha provocado que algunos
critiquen el tratamiento que recibe
amber riley en las redes sociales
mientras multitudes de fans han opinado
negativamente antes de que el jurado
haya tenido la oportunidad de emitir su
veredicto
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros y la ampliación también está en
francia 24 punto coma
[Música]